today our daily cancellation brings us
around full circle we began the show
talking about the efforts to place age
restrictions on pornography efforts that
have been furiously furiously protested
and denounced by smut Peddlers and smut
consumers alike both groups having
placed their own satisfaction far above
our basic responsibility as human beings
to protect children and we end the show
now on a related topic now I make no
secret to the fact that as I uh who
mentioned in the opening that I oppose
pornography across the board as a
general principle yes I want to see age
restrictions put in place but if I had
my way the entire industry would be
dismantled torn apart set on fire and
burned to Ash while we all gather
together and dance around at smoldering
corpse if I could do this by Banning
pornography entirely then I would as I
said earlier porn is nothing but cyber
prostitution and can be prohibited under
the same pretense and for the same
reason that prostitution is prohibited
already in most parts of the country
but a general porn ban is not going to
happen anytime soon much to my chagrin
which means that we can only chip away
at this demonic Behemoth piece by piece
by individual people deciding to
liberate themselves from its clutches
if we're going to land a blow it will
have to be landed by porn consumers
deciding to respect themselves and value
their own Souls enough to do something
else with their time and stop watching
porn
it's at this point that I'm often told
that
well it's not that simple uh porn users
can't just stop it's an addiction just
like being hooked on drugs literally no
difference at all that's what I'm always
assured I heard a lot of this same
rationalizing on Twitter this weekend
when the subject came up and one
commentator uh one commenter said quote
do you think it's easy for those who are
hooked on porn to just simply stop
watching porn think again it's an
addiction maybe worse than alcohol and
drugs another agreed and said Matt I
think you're amazing but you must not
have experience with a loved one's
addiction you're right that an addict
can just stop if you incentivize them to
do so but it's rarely that easy it's so
much more complicated than that another
chimed in quote the dopamine release
from porn is worse than most drugs you
can't just stop there are ramifications
many more of those came from you get the
idea these are the kinds of things
you'll hear anytime this topic is
discussed
so is it true that porn is an addiction
is porn addiction a real disorder
now typically critics of the porn
industry will say that porn addiction is
real because addiction has a negative
connotation and they recognize that porn
is a negative thing so they want to talk
about porn addiction Defenders of the
porn industry will deny that porn
addiction is real because addiction has
a negative connotation they refuse to
recognize that porn is a negative thing
so I find myself on a Lonely Island
because I am certainly not a porn
Defender though on the addiction issue I
think that they the porn Defenders have
arrived at the correct conclusion even
if their motives are totally deranged
meanwhile the porn critics have the best
intentions but when it comes to this
issue they're not only wrong but they
are inadvertently making the problem
worse
so what is addiction
the important point about addiction as
it's understood today is that it is
considered a disease the American
Psychiatric association calls addiction
quote a complex but treatable disease
that affects brain function and behavior
the NIH calls it a disease that is quote
a lot like other diseases like heart
disease goes on to explain that
addiction is a brain disorder the Mayo
Clinic also calls it a disease as for
the nature of this disease the NHS on
its website says this quote addiction is
defined as not having control over doing
taking or using something to the point
where it could be harmful to you
so addiction then is a disease that
takes away your ability to control your
own actions it is a dependency a
disorder
you know now I think talking about any
addiction this way can be potentially
dangerous as you're entirely removing
Free Will from the equation
but when it comes to something like
heroin addiction you can see where it
might apply
heroin takes over an addict's brain to
such an extent that if they simply just
stop taking it one day they might
actually die I mean they literally can't
stop not all at once anyway their body
depends on it
porn is not like this
if you lose your internet connection for
three days and you can't watch porn
you're not going to go into withdrawal
you're not going to break out into hives
you won't collapse on the ground in in
convulsions
you're not going to have a high fever
and seizures
you aren't going to have a heart attack
and die you'll be fine you can go
without it you might be a little bored a
little bit restless but you will be fine
you're not physically dependent on it
if you want some positive news in the
culture War since Roe v Wade was
overturned the left has lost their minds
making abortion their official Sacrament
the pro-life efforts which are now more
important than ever are booming you
heard that right despite the narrative
pro-lifers didn't go away they've
increased a number as one of the largest
pro-life organizations in the world no
one's in a better position than 40 Days
for life to end abortion in each state
in a post-rel America 40 Days for life
is changing hearts and Minds in the most
blue pro-abortion States they've had a
record number of locations since Rose
overturned and they grew in both
volunteers and locations with about a
million Volunteers in 1500 cities they
hold peaceful vigils outside abortion
facilities you can help them fight the
ongoing legal Battles by protecting free
speech for their volunteers by by giving
a tax deductible gift of any amount at
40daysforlife.com that's
40daysforlife.com
you could stop watching porn today
without much trouble
if I incentivized you enough right if if
you were incentivized enough you could
so if I were just to take an absurd
hypothetical if I were to offer you a
million dollars not to watch porn for a
week you could do it anyone could
now a million dollars might be enough to
help you break a heroin or alcohol
addiction but but probably not and
besides you'd still suffer the
potentially fatal ramifications of going
cold turkey off of those substances even
if there was a million dollars on the
table in other words a fat check could
not instantly release you of a true
substance addiction but it could release
you of your porn addiction
in that like you would be you would with
a million dollars on the table you would
stop watching porn easily without any
struggle
because the incentives are that high
what that means is that these addictions
are not the same because one is an
addiction and one is not
the other is a choice it's an Impulse
it's a temptation
you might very much enjoy watching porn
it might give you a dopamine hit
everything you enjoy gives you a
dopamine hit that does make it an
addiction though
unless of course we've decided that
literally everything is an addiction
which means that nothing is an addiction
see that's the thing here it's it's
possible to define the term addiction
broadly enough that you can include
pornography somebody sent me an article
from a site called medical news today
that defines porn addiction this way
quote porn addiction refers to an
emotional dependence on pornography that
interferes with daily life relationships
and the ability to function
so sure if that's how we Define the term
then porn addiction is a real phenomenon
but then you know in emotional
dependence that interferes with daily
life describes literally anything that
you enjoy doing too much
and in our Modern Age of materialism and
overindulgence that means we all have
like 50 different addictions
which means again that the term is
effectively meaningless and functionally
useless
we're using the same term to describe
the meth addict lying on a cardboard box
out on the streets
and the woman who spends too much on
Amazon packages
or the man scrolling PornHub
the latter two cases are obviously not
in the same ballpark as the first the
only thing we achieve by calling
everything an addiction by using
clinical terminology to describe all sin
all temptation all Vice
is that we let everybody off the hook
we've removed choice we have obliterated
free will
nobody has any control over anything
they're doing
which as we recall is a definition that
the NHS provides for addiction
when everything is an addiction we all
become pre-programmed robots right
victims of our own behavior our bad
choices are like cancerous tumors
they're they are in Affliction a disease
something we cannot control and
therefore cannot be blamed for
that's exactly how the ashamed porn user
has been conditioned to see his
situation he can't control it he can't
stop so he doesn't
this is how everybody has been
conditioned to view all of their
personal flaws and and sins and vices
and so we have become a society of
pathetic weaklings swept along
helplessly by the current
doing things making choices while while
telling ourselves that we have no
control over the things that we are
willfully doing right now
this is why we need to bring back a
concept called simple but not easy
remember what that one commenter said he
said you think it's easy for those who
are hooked to porn to just simply stop
watching porn
the answer is no and also yes
I do think I don't think it's easy
I don't think it's easy
but I do think it's simple
hard things are not always complicated
oftentimes they're very simple and
straightforward running 10 miles is
extremely simple it's a very simple
thing to do
it's also very hard
and when it comes to pornography the
task is as simple as it can get just
stop watching it
it's not making your life better it's
harming you psychologically spiritually
emotionally
you're sitting there and watching
someone else have sex on camera someone
who's almost certainly on drugs was
probably abused as a child
may very well have been trafficked could
actually be a child
this is a desperate self-loathing person
whose dehumanization and objectification
and despair you are consuming
now you don't feel good about that and
you shouldn't if you could go back and
reclaim all of the many hours you've
wasted on porn and retroactively
dedicated to something productive and
beautiful instead you would
you would like to stop watching it you'd
like to be free of it because porn is
dirty and disgusting and unmannly and
undignified and embarrassing and
shameful
and you realize all that intuitively
you want to be done with it which brings
us to the good news you can be done with
it you can stop watching it you can
decide not to watch it and then not
watch it and that's it
you don't need any drug or any treatment
plan or any special facility
you can just not watch it
and that's all
now this may sound like the least
helpful advice of all time but in many
cases it's the only kind of advice that
means anything
if you want to do something positive
with your life the best advice really
only advice anyone can give you is to
Simply go and do that thing
you can sit around saying I really wish
I would do this then just do it that's
it that's the only thing the world can
tell you oh you want to do that well
then go ahead and do it
but I can't well yes you can but I can't
well okay then just sit there saying you
can't
what do you want us to tell you
and if you want to stop doing something
negative again the best advice and only
advice anyone can give you is to Simply
stop doing that thing
I'm doing this but I don't want to do it
well then don't
but it's hard okay well it's hard so
just
it's a difficult thing that's it endure
the difficulty
that's it
and that's advice that you can follow
with porn because it's not an addiction
it's a lot of other things
none of them good
but it's not an addiction
and that is why porn addiction has a
concept
is today canceled if you'd like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt wall Show
Twitter page hope to see you there
Godspeed